good evening everyone it is almost six
o'clock
so you just want to make sure that you
all can hear me of your microphones
ready to go
we'll have the governor come up here in
just a second if anyone else needs to
take a seat we have a few more
and we'll be good to go can you all hear
me okay well the governor's louder than
i am so that'll be good
and i think i'm gonna whip out my phone
it's six o'clock so with that i'm going
to introduce governor sislak and we'll
get started
thank you megan appreciate it
good afternoon what a beautiful place to
have our second
raffle drawing for our winners uh lake
tahoe which is one of the
beautiful sights in nevada thank you for
coming to our second
of eight live winter announcements that
we're going to have for vax nevada days
a celebration of cobit 19 vaccines
and the nevadans who are choosing to
protect themselves
their loved ones and our communities by
getting vaccinated
i'm so happy to be here at sand harbor
today before we
go any further i want to give my thanks
to bob burgel
administrator of the nevada division of
state parks
jonathan brunges and i apologize if i'm
mispronouncing these
deputy administrators from the bad
division of state parks
and alan wooldridge park supervisor lake
tahoe nevada state park for helping me
get this all set up
i think you'll all probably agree with
me they've got tough job locations to
work at when you're working at sand
harbor
i'd also like to take a moment to thank
all the people working tirelessly around
the state
to get as many cobit 19 vaccines into as
many arms as possible
in nevada some of whom are with me this
evening like the team at immunized
nevada
and also nikki aker from carson city
health and human services
thank you for being here and thank you
for the work you do to create a
healthier nevada
this is truly a breathtaking location
and it's just
one of so many amazing state parks that
we have right here in nevada
throughout max nevada days almost 500
nevadans will win
annual park passes and be able to spend
time in our great outdoors
before we get to tonight's exciting
announcements i want to provide an
update on how we are continuing
to fight covet 19 and ensure that all
nevadans have access
to the covid19 vaccine
as always copit9 vaccine is free
it is safe and it is effective and it's
available to nevadans 12 years old
and older no id no insurance is required
for the vaccine
and you can find a site near you at
nvcovidfighter.org
that's ndcovidfighter.org
as you know the state of nevada recently
requested resources from fema
to support our mission particularly in
southern nevada
and we are excited for them to join us
in that outreach
along with state and local partners
members of the fema team have been
meeting with partners this week
and will begin their southern nevada
operation this weekend
nevada has risen ahead of the u.s
vaccine first dose trends which is
exciting
to start moving back forward with two
percent of eligible nevadans receiving
their first dose
last week which is higher than the
national average
of 1.1.5 percent nearly 740 first doses
per 100 000 people were administered
last week
which is also well above the national
average of 250.
and while the state and local partners
in clark county have been working
hard to increase vaccinations clark is
still
experiencing increasing cases positivity
and hospitalizations we are leveraging
every resource we have
to ensure nevadans have access to covet
19 testing
and to the vaccines we are so grateful
that leaders
in our state's largest industry have
joined us in this effort to protect the
help of our residents and visitors
this saturday vaccination and testing
will be available on the las vegas strip
at park mgm adjacent to
from 10 a.m to 6 p.m the event will
offer testing
and all three vaccines for those aged 12
and older
mgm resorts has agreed to offer some
really exciting giveaways
for those who attend the event and now
i'm excited to reveal some of the
winners
i know a few of them are here with us
today so let's start with the college
savings plan winner
overall 10 lucky students in nevada
between the ages of 12 and
17 won the drawing to get a 5 000
scholarship and tonight i'll be
announcing
six of those winners i have an envelope
here
that has the names of the six lucky
winners
i feel like you know this is the oscars
with the six winners are vanitra m from
las vegas
ethan a from las vegas
langdon i from reno
stephen m from fallon samuel r
from las vegas and jaden b from las
vegas they are winners of the five
thousand dollar college savings plans
and now moving right along
to get that back in the envelope
congratulations to all of our five
thousand dollar winners
our savings plans and it's time to
announce the three
twenty thousand dollar college savings
winners
overall three lucky students won
twenty thousand dollar college savings
plan prizes
and tonight i'm excited to announce all
three of these winners
one who is able to join us for this
announcement
and the winners are bernardo l from las
vegas
kyle lim from clark county and jonah h
from reno
we have jonah here
never stops
is johnny here with us this evening you
want to come on up jonah we've got us
a check for you
[Music]
[Applause]
a 20 000 college scholarship for jonah
nice job jonah congratulations take it
with you we'll call you for a picture
congratulations to bernardo kyle and
jonah
it is now with great pride that i
announced this week's
50 000 tuition winner
this is truly a life-changing dollar
amount
that will allow this young nevadan the
opportunity to pursue
any higher education they choose
hunter m from henderson i hope you're
watching from home
congratulations congratulations
to all the young 529 tuition savings
plan winners
and now to today's cash winners
as a reminder all covid
vaccinated nevadans over the age of 18
are entered into our cash drawings and
this week's prizes range from one
thousand dollars
to fifty thousand dollars there were ten
one thousand dollar winners this week
i am pleased to announce eight winners
this evening
sue d from las vegas teresa w
from reno madison r from reno
wendy p from las vegas charles w
from henderson daryl l from minden
dana v from minden and hannah l from las
vegas
are all 10 a 1 000 cash winners
congratulations to all of you all of our
thousand dollar winners
and now for this week's 25
and 50 thousand dollar winners during
week two of acts nevada
four nevadans are being awarded twenty
five thousand dollars
and one nevadan will earn fifty thousand
dollars
tonight i will be announcing three of
our 25
000 winners and this week's one
grand prize 50 000 dollar winner
i know one of our 25 thousand dollar
winners plan to be here this evening
and one of our in our fifty thousand
dollar grand prize winner
was uh is supposed to be here with us
this evening i don't know these people
so we will see when they call the names
first our 25 thousand dollar winners
from las vegas rose marie v
from las vegas beverly r
and with us tonight i believe we have
jacqueline
c from carson city and our fifty
thousand dollar winner
is chloe h from carson city if you wanna
come on up we'd like to give you a
symbolic check
come on up
right yes here you go
thank you so much congratulations
thank you thank you we'll get some more
pictures and our 50 000
winner congratulations
chloe is a recent graduate of carson
city high school of carson high school
so i'm sure this will help as you choose
your next steps and along your path
of your future congratulations it's nice
she's got family here with her to join
in the experience
before we wrap up tonight's announcement
i want to share
a story from this week's winner outreach
when our team contacts our big cash
winners we don't tell them how much
they've won
only that they have won cash well it
turns out we have a new
cobit 19 vaccine ambassador in nevada
as rose marie from las vegas was so
excited to hear she had won
something she's been spreading the word
and she tells us she's been able to
encourage some of her family
her friends and even one grocery store
clerk to get the vaccine
so rosemary thank you that's what this
program is all about
encouraging nevadans to seek this
life-saving treatment
i want to encourage all the vets who
have been vaccinated
to be like rosemary and help your
friends
your family and your neighbors get
connected to the covid19 vaccine
and remember there's still time for all
of you to still
participate we ask you to go get your
vaccine you will automatically be
entered in our remaining drawings during
vax nevada days
including our 1 million dollar grand
prize
that we'll be drawing at our last live
reveal which is on august 26th
so please get vaccinated you can protect
against covet 19
and also you can be entered into the
drawing to win
thank you all for joining us here
tonight in this beautiful at beautiful
sand harbor
i'll look forward to next week's
announcement and again encourage all of
you to get vaccinated
to our winners that are present and
extra special thank you for being here
and participating with us we appreciate
all that you're doing
thank you all go out and get vaccinated